المشكله انه انا اللي مصادفها تنمر اول
الشي
ما عم يتقبلوني يعني انا احيانا كتير حاجه
للنساء يعني بس واحد عم يتقبل هذا الموضوع
لهلا
[موسيقى]
ايمان ام عبد الغني من مدينه حماه المدينه
تقريبا الي سنتين بالباب والي سنه بشتغل
بشتغل سائق السياره للنساء فقط يعني
[موسيقى]
ناقص خمسه
كيف بدنا نعيش انا ما عندي شهادات اول
الشي تمام عندي شهاده بس تاسع
يعني بدي اقول لك مبسوطه لانه انا مو
بحاجه حدا بس ماني مبسوطه لانه عم بتعب
احيانا دراسه الاولاد تجيني تليفون الساعه
12 بالليل انه انا وحده عم تلعب وحده بدي
وصلها من هون لهون وفي رجال هون كتير
محافظين اهل الباب يعني المراه ما فينا
تطلع مع شوفير يعني الا مع شوفيره
واحيانا بتخرب معي السياره بالطريق يعني
هيك بس بدبر حالي يعني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]